yes so maybe then uh that we don't don't
spend so much time ever i guess everyone
knows nate
nate uh we consider nate as uh one of
our own since he's after all working in
formal methods verification
network and synthesis but from when i
also see him in some of his other
environment
networking people also consider him his
own you know like he's publishing
regular
uh nsdic com and other networking
conferences he has done
amazing work in the uh p4 programming
language which is used for network
networks and uh since we're on the type
constraints nate please uh just start uh
go ahead with presentation thank you
thank you for agreeing to give a talk
yeah thank you for inviting me i was um
remembering back when
i think this workshop or series was
being planned
um talking to you and yeah bubble and
others and uh
i think i even asked my chair if you
know maybe i could spend have a lighter
teaching load this semester to spend
some time in berkeley so the pandemic
obviously changed everything but um
it's nice to be here on zoom
nevertheless um
let me first acknowledge this is uh i'm
going to talk about some pretty old work
um there's some newer stuff i could have
talked about but i was my student was
perhaps going to give the fourth talk
today but
i didn't feel like he could have talked
together in time so this is older work
with um judd mcclure who's now at um
colorado school of mines
uh hussein hojo who's now in tehran
pablo tourney who's now in austria
in vienna and then todd and andrew who
were
cornell undergrads um now in the bay
area
um so the context is software defined
networking which
probably most of you have heard of but
i'll just tell you what you need to know
for the purposes of this talk
um so the idea in software-defined
networking is that um
the sort of two traditional planes of a
network
the control plane and the data plane um
get
uh decoupled from each other and both
sort of given a programming api
so the data plane which is the piece of
the network that actually moves packets
around
can be customized using some kind of
simple
typically hardware oriented language and
i'll just call these things switches
you can think of these as encompassing
routers and gateways and firewalls and
even some middle boxes but i'll just
call them switches
um and then the control plane which
in a you know in the internet is things
like routers running bgp
or other other kinds of devices now just
becomes
a standard uh server that runs you know
a program written in java
and there may be you know one controller
for many switches
there could be many controllers as well
um but basically you get to choose the
code that runs up here in the control
plane
and the way that the control plane and
data plane interact
is that because they've been separated
from each other you now need some kind
of api
so there's a configuration api that lets
the controller
do things like push down you know new
entries into routing tables
which will change the behavior of the
switches
so if you want to customize the network
you know you can write a program that
does something different
um so one of the kind of fundamental
questions that
one quickly stumbles upon if you start
trying to write programs for sdn
controllers
uh is you know how are you going to
transition the network from
one global configuration if you set up
the network to implement
a bunch of forwarding paths um and then
something changes
maybe you know maybe a new host comes
online
maybe it's apology uh you know some link
fails or some device fails and you
decide to change which paths you're
using
or maybe the network becomes congested
and you want to move some
of the traffic flows over to different
paths so you'd like to transition the
network to some
different configuration where you know
you've routed around the failure or
you've rebalanced the load
um so you know with with sdn you have
the power to do this
you can you have this sort of
conceptually at least a single program
that's sort of in charge of the whole
network um but
you need to transition the network from
you know the upstairs red configuration
here to the downstairs blue
configuration
and of course you know a network's
typically a live system so
we can't just sort of stop the world and
uh
and sort of you know deploy the blue
configuration instead
at some granularity we're going to step
through
a series of intermediate configurations
um until we ultimately get to the to the
final configuration
um so you know in this in these two sort
of cartoons here
you see that you know some of the
switches are still in the old
configuration
and some are in the new um and then
we're sort of gradually moving across to
the new configuration
so of course the obvious problem
especially if you're a formal methods
person is that
um the programmer who you know was
writing this control program
who carefully designed the red
network-wide configuration in the blue
network configuration may have had some
important
global invariance in mind like maybe the
red
configuration you know connects all the
hosts
as does the blue but it's not obvious
that if you start
mixing and matching sort of pieces of
code from the red and the blue
that these invariants will be preserved
um and so uh the
the problem that we're gonna study is
you know how can we come up with ways of
doing
implementing these transitions i'll call
them network updates while ensuring that
in all these intermediate states
um we're not somehow violating uh
important properties in the network
so let me give you a concrete example
just to make this a little bit more
crisp let's suppose that we're looking
at a data center network
data centers are one of the places where
sdn makes a lot of sense
um because you know you have sort of one
entity that's in charge of the data
center so
you don't you don't have to worry about
sort of different administrative domains
or who's in charge it's like just you
know
the data center is in charge and let's
suppose that we want to
implement a change where i go from this
solid blue path
that goes from h1 to h3 via this
uh first core router at the top of our
of our tree here
um to the red path which is shown dashed
because it's not yet active
which also goes from h1 to h3 but it
chooses to go via this
c2 instead of instead of by c1
so um i'm not going to dwell too much on
sort of the details of how these sdn
switches are programmed
um as as rizika said there's a whole
interesting rich story there
actually for the purposes of this talk
i'm going to sort of pretend
that each switch is implements a a
function
and the sort of control plane operation
i have is to zap a switch and plunk down
a new function so i can take that you
know atomically i can take
sort of each switch and and whack it and
move it from red to blue
um what i can't do of course is to sort
of whack the entire network to
transition it over
um so you know here's one way i could i
could implement this update i could
um update t1 that's my top of rack
switch here that h1 is connected to
and then i could update a1 and then i
could update c2 and then
a3 and uh uh
the the final switch i don't update
because it's just connected directly to
h3
so let's see what happens if i do this
um so i'll update t1
as i said oh sorry my animation here
skipped over something let me just
decide to go back um
so uh the the thing you might worry
about is you know
is it possible for uh the property that
both the red path and the blue path
uh ensure which is that h1 you know
consent packet stage three
is that property give me invariant and
the problem is probably you're
anticipating is
um depending on the order of these
updates
um and in particular how they're
intermixed with
packets that might be in flight i can
end up um
i can end up in a state where the
packets are actually dropped so here
let's start sending a packet um
and sorry this animation looks i just
tested these out and it went different
oh sorry
give me just a sec this is this is the
good animation so in the initial state
uh packets get from h1 to h3
on the blue path no problem but now
let's consider that we start updating
the switches so we update t1
so now we're using the red path happens
to go to the same place so there's no
actual operational change and then we
update a1
um and now you see that actually the
path from h1 gets to c2 but
if this dash line you know isn't yet
active then
at this point packets can't proceed and
so um
what we've done is we've created a black
hole right we stitched together
uh a sort of prefix of paths from the
red
and then you know there's no
corresponding suffix from paths from the
blue that will get us to the destination
so this creates a black hole and you
know i'm pretty going to see this but
you
we ran a little simulation when doing
this work just to show that it's
actually the case
if you code up this network and run it
in a little sdm environment
you know you can see that um basically
there's a
dip where you know we're just streaming
packets from h1 to h3 and
for a little while like even a few
seconds
until the update goes through uh packets
are lost
um and it's not just connectivity um
here's another example
uh showing how these sort of naive
updates where you just do things in a
certain order can can go wrong
so here there's an extra property that i
want in addition to getting packets from
h1 h3
i want them to always go through
one of these boxes that has a check next
to it so
pretend this is some kind of you know
firewall or special middle box
and it's important to me that uh that
traffic that's going from h183 traverse
one of these
special boxes uh perhaps it's gonna
filter or protect me against
any bad traffic coming from h1 um so
again
you know if um if i implement the update
in a certain order here you know t1
a2 and then i send packets well now
you know the packets do get through but
i've gone from a situation where
you know on the blue path i went across
the the filtering device here a1
and on the red path i would go through
this filtering device but by stitching
together
um you know i got a prefix of red with
the suffix with blue i can evade
the the middle box which was supposed to
do my filtering
um and so it's a transient failure a
transient bug
um but it could be very important i mean
if if this is something that a cloud
provider is doing to you and you're
renting vms and suddenly
the you know isolation between different
tenants that you were promised
is is transitly broken um i think you'd
be pretty upset
um so this can lead to things like
access control or security violations
so you might wonder you know is this
really a problem um
are these kinds of transient bugs uh
really an issue and
uh this is sort of a cheap shot but um a
kind of fun pastime of people who work
on applying formal methods to networks
is to go through
postmortems of uh of you know outages
um and i guess the uh i won't claim that
this is due to some you know path
property that got broken but
uh it's always fun to kind of go and see
that often you know implementing these
network configuration changes
is actually sort of identified as one of
the root causes
of of you know more complicated bugs
that end up affecting
you know whole data centers or whole
cloud services
can you just give an example so uh we
were recently looking in infrastructure
as code in
amazon in exactly this problem that you
set like mutual dependencies so when
you're
setting up uh your server you have this
something depends on the other
and uh what was funny if you you know
like there's so many options
that you know like more that regular
user cannot use them but what we
what we showed that actually both we
managed to
uh simply run that user would
leak all the data both in the i mean
in amazon cloud and in google cloud
and the the reason for this i i just
want to see i could send you
but the reason for this was exactly what
you should revert you showed
you know like you update one
authentication server but you don't
update the other
and then you actually link the date i
mean of course it was our own personal
data i mean
fake personal data but it's uh you know
it's not just like
this could happen it really did happen
we have uh uh
on both amazon and google is showing
that this uh thing uh
leads to the this inconsistent updates
lead
uh to failures and uh leakage of the
data
wonderful um one more thing i'll say
since you're since we're drawing on this
um uh this kind of technique of course
uh is also useful even within
kind of one device um so internally
uh high speed routers and switches are
little networks they have parallelism
they have multiple processing pipelines
um and they have a topology and yet they
present a management interface that
allows
you know a control plane or an operator
working on the cli to
to make you know what appear to be
instantaneous and atomic updates to the
state of the device
um so some of these techniques also
apply just within one device
when you want to do updates and there
you know it's really part of the
guarantee that the the device
manufacturer is promising you um
and you know if you get it wrong your
device is kind of spraying packets in
the wrong you know maybe the wrong
packets out the wrong ports or dropping
packets that shouldn't be dropped
um which again can be a big problem
and you know that's funny when we
reported the bugs they told us
yeah yeah it's not bad it's actually uh
customers that in charge themselves to
take care of that
so one um one way to solve this problem
and this is something we did in a paper
in
sitcom 12 so nine years ago um was
you know kind of looking at this through
a programming language lens
it seemed kind of clear to to us that
well we should give some kind of
abstraction we should sort of
have the controller allow you to make
a network-wide change and then there
will be a runtime system that's sort of
responsible for implementing that
semantics and
there's you know several different
guarantees you could imagine for
what that you know transaction like
uh abstraction for network update should
look like
um but one that seems very natural that
i'll focus on today is that
every packet kind of sees a single
policy version
so the idea is that you know even though
the network itself will step through
intermediate configurations where some
devices are in the old and some are in
the new
you'll carefully arrange things so that
so that every uh packet you know end to
end
only sees the old or only sees the new
um
and there's a rich space of mechanisms
for doing this
one that is general and particularly
simple is something we call the
two-phase update
and the idea here is that you can um
basically add an extra tag
to all of the device configurations and
the tag
encodes which version are we in are we
in the old are we in the new
and then you can go around and install
in the interior of the network
um the new configuration side by side
with the old
so you now have sort of two copies of
the of the configuration
um but they're both predicated on sort
of a test you know my invert
am in the old am i in the new um and
then you can go around the edge
and you can safely upgrade sort of edge
devices
to the new configuration so note that in
this sort of this state here
you know the the new configuration is
available but all of the edge
devices are still in the old
configuration so essentially the new
configuration's not being used
and then you can go around the edge in
any order you like so here you know the
the right-hand side's been upgraded but
the left-hand side still in the old
version
but you know that packets originating
you know on this side will
will be processed for the new and on
this side of the old and then eventually
you do everything and then you can go
delete the old
field configuration so this two phase
update you know implements this
uh network wide update with per packet
consistent guarantee this this guarantee
up here
um so it's great except that it doubles
the
amount of memory that you need on
switches and it also
takes you know several rounds uh to to
implement um you have to go sort of do
things in these carefully staged rounds
and you have to actually insert
what are called barrier messages to make
sure that sort of all the packets that
were in the network
um you know in each phase have been
flushed before you proceed
um so there's a theorem that we proved
in this sitcom paper
um which is uh i think a nice
characterization it's that a network is
per packet consistent
if and only if it preserves all safety
properties um so you can think of safety
properties as being the path properties
the paths that uh the set of paths that
a packet takes
and so this leads to sort of a couple of
questions um
you know one is can we always implement
perfect consistent updates
by just updating individual switches in
the right order
so in other words without adding version
tags without
you know doubling the amount of memory
could we just go find a careful order
of updating maybe switches or rules um
so that we get perpendicular consistency
and if the answer to that question is no
then you know this all safety properties
is a pretty strong guarantee
it's very nice as a user because it says
you know the update scheme doesn't need
to know about the invariance it's
supposed to
to guard but it's kind of it's guarding
them all automatically
um but if if that's too strong you know
maybe that's a thing we can play with we
can give
programmers a way to say which
properties they want to preserve and
then we can
um get by with a better scheme um so
here's a couple more examples just
showing you
um uh sort of you know for these
for these topologies and these
configurations um there actually are
update uh updates you can do that
are uh simple in the sense that all
we're gonna do is update entire devices
and we'll do that at most once for each
device um so we're not going to add
version tags we're not going to
um we're not going to have double the
rules on each switch
so here if we update you know t1 then
c2 then a3 then
a1 um then that actually preserves
um you know for these configurations
that will preserve
all uh all packet properties
um and it's kind of easy to see because
essentially what we're doing here is
what an industry is called sort of make
before break we're sort of setting up
the
the red path and then there's one switch
where we can do the swap over to
uh to the from from the blue the red um
but this other scenario i showed you
with the the
you know the special firewall devices
that we wanted to reverse
um you can go through you know any of
the orders you want
um uh here's here's a couple um
so we could try to do a2 first and then
a4 and then t1 and then
c1 um but uh you can see that there's
a kind of interesting dependency here
based on what happens
sort of on t1 and c1 um and it turns out
that for this example
there's no update we could do no order
that we could update the switches that
would ensure perfect consistency
but there's a little insight which is
well if we
relax from you know per packet
consistency which preserves all
properties to just
make sure that packets are eventually
delivered and we go via a1 or a4
then now there's a small tweak we can do
which
which will get us there so if we update
a2 first then
a4 and then c1 and then t1
now we are there are some packets that
will take a different path than red or
blue
um but packets will get from h1 to h3
and will always go through one of these
special devices
so that's the idea that we're going to
use to do this work so we're going to
come up with a way to use
synthesis to generate these
update plans these programs that update
switches in a particular order
that are guaranteed to enforce or to
preserve certain properties
and so why is this kind of why is
networking a good domain for synthesis
um i guess the intuition that i would
give is that
the complexity here is that the the sort
of you can model a network as being a
sort of
a kind of program right each switch is
sort of implementing a function on
packets
the topology is also including a
function on packets and these programs
get really big but they're simple and
highly structured for example you know
we can
most networks and most network
configurations are designed to be free
of loops
so in fact they become just the sort of
finite functions on
packets which themselves are are you can
think of as sort of finite records of
bits
um so that's good a second
reason that i think synthesis is a great
fit here is that
the desired behavior of a network uh is
often something that
an operator has in their mind um they
might not write it down formally
but they have these properties that they
want like you know no black holes
or traverse the firewall or you know
connect all hosts um
and so the most difficult aspects of
these network updates
is that you've got uh limited resources
limited memory on the on the switches
and you have a lot of concurrency
um because you have packets that are in
flight and you know a distributed system
that you're updating
so how much time do i have by the way my
clock here says 25 minutes i'm worried
i'm running way late but i think i
started my clock early do i have about
five more minutes
is that a yes
yes you can go please okay i'll try to
finish in about five minutes
um so for how to specify properties um i
guess for this crowd it'll be obvious
what we did but
we just use ltl formulas um so
you know things like reachability like
making sure that every packet that
starts at some source eventually gets to
its destination
of course can be written down as just a
conjunction of very simple
formulas that basically asserts that if
we start from
s1 we event we in the future get to the
destination
um waypointing which captures those
properties we had in the
firewall example we can encode using an
until
and then you can even do service
chaining which makes sure that you know
you don't just go through one way point
but
maybe you go through a sequence of uh of
these middle boxes in some specified
order
this is often important in um in certain
networks
so uh our synthesis tool then takes in
um the initial and final configurations
of the network
um it takes in an ltl specification of
what properties
we uh we want the the network to
preserve during the update
and you can think of it conceptually as
taking in sort of a
some constraints from the domain here
the essential constraint is that
we're only going to search for updates
that update each switch entirely
so we're not going to partially update a
switch we're always going to update the
entire switch
and we're only going to update each
switch once
so we're not going to you know update um
we're not going to go update a switch
and then come back and revisit that
decision later
so we call these these simple updates
and so you know in a fairly
straightforward way we pass this into
our synthesizer and what we get out is a
a sequence of uh switches to to update
in a certain order
um conceptually this is you know we're
basically doing
a kind of search of course um
so you can think of this as you know we
start from the old configuration
and then i draw sort of switches that
have been updated to the new
configuration in blue
so each of these nodes in this graph
we can model you know the function that
the network implements
and we can check if it satisfies our
property so the old one
by assumption does we we check that but
if the old configuration doesn't have a
sales by the property we just stop and
say
sorry you gave me a bad program as well
as the new
and then what we're looking for is a way
to you know
make local moves updating one switch at
a time
um until we get all the way to the to
the to the new configuration down here
at the right
where the pat in the path we follow the
specification holds at every
step um i'll defer the details to our
pldi paper you can
read about there here's the pseudo code
in a figure but the basic idea is to do
a sort of depth-first search um through
the topology
attempting to update switches one by one
and whenever we reach a bad
configuration
we backtrack and make a different choice
for what to try next
um the main challenge is making this
fast of course the search base is huge
and at each step we're checking uh a
configuration against a ltl
specification so this is doing a model
checking problem
and so the two main ideas that we use to
make this fast
uh one is the standard you know we learn
from counter examples
and we try to uh distill them down to
uh sort of small characterizations that
let us rule out
uh other paths we might follow later
quickly um
and the other technical insight which uh
paul came up with which i think is quite
slick is
because our configurations we assume
that they're loop-free we check that
they're loop-free
we can actually use a incremental model
checker
that takes you know the old
the old crippy structure that we were
model checking uh in some previous step
and then make some change some you know
change like updating a switch and then
go uh remodel check uh faster than if we
had to do it from scratch
so i'll just show you this in one slide
here's a sort of it's a little bit of a
cartoon
but uh think of this left thing as being
the
the transition system or the crippy
structure for you know
one of the states that we reach and then
we decide to do an update maybe of this
switch labeled k
and so in doing that update you know
some of its local properties will change
um as well as the connections to other
states because we might have changed how
the network forwards
um but uh because our networks are loot
free
these kripke structures are we call them
dag-like the only loops are kind of
these self-loops
um and so uh again you can see our paper
but there's a
really nice algorithm for incrementally
relabeling uh the nodes
so that um you get back to a prickly
structure that then
is fully annotated and you can check the
property um so for example here
um even though this node changed from
you know
future a to future b um after sort of
locally
updating the annotations here we don't
have to do anything at the parent
because the parent
still satisfies the same the same
property
so that's important helping us speed up
you might wonder does this always work
and the answer is no there are some
scenarios where
is no correct ordering um at least
assuming our at most one updates where
we're not modifying the configurations
on
any switch and the kind of key gadget
that that breaks this kind of synthesis
is what we call the double diamond
um so here there's you know the old
configuration is shown here on the
bottom
the new on the top um and there's a
a cycle right you can't update h1nc
together and so you're gonna end up
um you can end up in a in a state where
you're in a mixture of gold and new
and if the property that you care about
uh requires
you know per packet consistency like
either the old path or the new path
um then then you're screwed um our disk
16 paper spells this out
um so in practice what we do in these
situations is we just fall back to the
more expensive
two-face update let me just quickly show
you a little bit of evaluation
um so we're interested in of course the
scalability of our approach
and how well our optimizations help we
ran this on
some realistic topologies but with
synthetic configurations because we
didn't have access to
railroad configurations and we took some
kind of common properties
reachability waypointing and so on um
so here's a little graph just showing
scalability um
so this is for uh three different
properties
the green here is reachability so just
making sure that every host can talk to
every other host
the blue is way pointing so going
through
you know one node on the way and the red
is a
service chaining example where we go
through a sequence of nodes
um and so i guess the key takeaways here
are these are for
scenarios that were feasible um it's
that you can
scale this out to you know around a
thousand switches for our kind of little
prototype
um uh in sort of you know tens or
hundreds of seconds um for symbol
properties and
but as you write down more complicated
properties unsurprisingly the cost of
synthesis
goes up um we also ran this against some
infeasible scenarios
so these are ones with this double
diamond where the property distinguished
that
and uh as you can see uh you know
even though we're doing essentially an
exhaustive search um we're not
completely blowing up compared to the
feasible cases
the optimizations really help so we did
a comparison against
uh clever but uh but sort of standard
encoding using new smb
and then here's our model checker
working incrementally and you see that
it
scales much better this is just for
doing
shortest path forwarding in different
topologies with all bears reachability
as the specification
um so i'll leave you here with um with
some pointers to papers
um just to say kind of where this has
gone because this is work that's five
years old now so
um these kinds of update techniques are
used in clouds
um so it's a real problem um and there's
i think where the frontier is
is of course making these techniques
faster and so on um
and relaxing requirements like the
simple updates that update
one switch at a time but another big
area is
incorporating quantitative properties um
so
you know if if the reason that you're
updating the network is to help out with
traffic engineering
then you'd be sad if doing this kind of
update induced more congestion
than what you had initially um so
there's some nice work out of microsoft
and eth
um doing updates that can uh give bounds
on the congestion that's induced by the
update
um and there's uh contemporary work like
you know being published this year
um that looks in that direction as well
all right i'll stop there because i
think i'm over time
and maybe take some questions
so unfortunately i just got the message
that uh next speaker needs to leave at
30 precisely
so okay no no no is it okay that
you give uh you take questions after a
new
answer now in question and answer
session if you see we have here q and a
people can ask the q a
and then afterwards you ask different
more questions sure
okay thank you
um so i think we can we can move to our
next speaker
uh alvin are you online
yeah i'm here can you hear me yeah go
ahead yeah go ahead and share screen
okay um so it's my pleasure to introduce
our next
speaker alvin chung who is a assistant
professor at
uc berkeley alvin has been working
at the intersection of programming
languages
and database and data intensive systems
for for many years now um and
uh he has done amazing work in program
synthesis and related topics
that has been recognized by many awards
he's got a dozen awards
uh both for his thesis work and early
early career awards um from various
companies including google
intel vmware and uh he's been recognized
by the ieee
uh tcd the data engineering committee as
well as uh sigmoid the acm sigmoid
uh organization for his work so uh
without further ado
uh alvin the floor is yours great thank
you so much sanjay then good morning
everyone
uh thanks for giving me the opportunity
to speak to you this morning
you